je n'ai attaqué jamais personne en
dessous de la ceinture comme je les ai
entendus dire j'ai simplement poser des
questions sur des clarifications qui me
paraissait nécessaire et j'en ai
d'autres reposer sur d'autres sujets
nous avons observé
et je ne dis pas que c'est à la demande
de françois fillon c'est n'était
évidemment pas la demande de françois
fillon nous avons pire des cas un
certain nombre de gens qui étaient très
marquée à l'extrême droite que ce soient
des individus ou parfois des groupements
lancé parfois sur les réseaux sociaux
des appels à voter pour la candidature
de françois fillon moi j'ai été clair on
va vous le connaissez je vais pas déçu
je suis bon par monsieur carl lang
riposte laïque etc je vous laisse le
choix vous le verrez au fil des jours
l'élégant fut voulue qu'avec la
dynamique de fillon et puisse dire bien
non il ya une dynamique
moi je me retire et puis voilà ça aurait
été très gaullien il sortait de de la
politique il entré dans l'histoire là il
rentre dans la politique politicienne et
on voit que il va perdre en étant devenu
un type hargneux méchant agressif c'est
encore une attaque inutile politicienne
qui n'a pas de sens mais vous a prévenu
dès le dimanche quand elle lit je
continuerai le combat
effectivement la tension est montée hier
françois fillon a répondu alain juppé
sur un ton un peu un peu sec et donc
voilà il ya une petite escarmouche dans
la journée d'hier il a dit je veux
casser la baraque vraiment à plusieurs
reprises je crois même qu'il l'a répété
hier soir j'ai j'ai vu ça en passant est
rapide moins d'histoires sur eux
peut-être sur france 2 alors sur tf1
peut-être que j'affirme qu'il faut
casser la baraque pour la reconstruire
autrement
alors on me rétorque que je vais trop
loin je pense que cette idée de casser
la baraque est une idée dangereuse pour
la société française
j'ai travaillé avec monsieur fillon
quand nous étions tous les deux premiers
c'est un excellent négociateur qui
défend toujours son point de vue et qui
le fait avec constance c'est un grand
professionnel il faut pas avoir les clés
aime trop sensible et jouer les
chochottes
pendant toute la campagne du premier
tour j'étais accusé d'être trop mou oui
bah je dis aujourd'hui que fillon est
trop dur part à ce match nul
je n'ai pas fait exactement le score que
j'aurais pu souhaiter c'est une vraie
scission la droite je suis quand même le
seul qui a réussi à faire mentir les
sondages en faisant moins que un peu les
deux candidats que vous venez de voir on
était sur votre chaîne sur un canapé
parler de leur vie autrement que un film
le fait on leur fait aucun procès mais
peut-être vous irez bientôt aussi mais
je me battrai pour mes idées pour mon
pays même pas contre quelqu'un donc je
souhaite bonne chance et bon courage
quiconque l'emportera dimanche prochain
son programme c'est lui c'est juste lui
donc on est vraiment dans le fin fond de
la politique médiatique et virtuels sais
je suis moi même le projet d'ailleurs en
marche c'est em ce sont ces initiales on
peut pas mieux dire que le projet d'
emmanuel macron c'est sa personne